io sto distruggendo tutto no e cese ha
schiantato un moscerino sulla webcam
perfetto mentre registro fantastico
tutti ragazzi che sono video sono fa dj
ed oggi come tutti i mesi siamo tornati
in un episodio di game testa sigla
mi sento un bambino quando lanciò la
sigla è troppo vero con che regga solo
il gioco di oggi e adventure time come
il primo episodio di che in testa non ne
ho più fatti i videogame su adventure
time ma ne hanno fatti li strafighi nel
maine voglio nominare jane tester
dell'ultimo mese che è stato vinto da
pierre ci hanno scritto qua perché non
mi dico a pierfrancesco ciao io non le
ha memoria cielo corta mi ricordavo
soltanto piero piero via il francesco da
martinsicuro cominciamo con salta fin e
il bello è che c'è j che gli sta tirando
un calcione nel deretano e c'è film
tutto contento che salta vabbè contento
lui fermi comunque prima di cominciare
una cosa devo farvi assolutamente vedere
la vedete ragazzi dei tiri della qua
dietro io non vorrei dire ragazzi è però
ne vado fiero ma troppo tesoro fammi
compagnia in questo episodio a parte che
ciò caldo bestia tipo morino di caldo
merita troppo per non esser messa nel
video e merita troppo per non essere
ammessa nel video ragazzi salta film
primo video che in di oggi sicuro di
voler ricominciare non ho mai cominciato
in vita mia
spiegami fine il re ghiaccio ha rapito
la principessa
la portata nella sua fortezza della
landa ghiacciata come possiamo
raggiungerla ci sono è tempo di prendere
qualcuno a calci volete che ci aveva un
senso la schermata iniziale prende calci
nel deretano senza motivo prove
bellissimo di ricerche chilometri orari
e che cos'è un treno nuovi jake sotto
film così che possa rimbalzare a figo se
devo avere st precisione io chi ficcata
saltelli in saltelli noè ci mancava
quello zio sono morto era grazie j che è
andato a comprare e brio ha quindi ho
solo una possibilità di rimbalzare a ok
non lo sapeva di che lo guarda con
contento di volare
fare clic per calciare fin in aria e
faccio nel di dietro ai ragazzi è
bellissimo 163 stelle vara è stato
guarda spettacolare va bene anche così
quindi io devo potenziarli perché se non
ci arriverò mai al castello giusto che
sta volando film e ho capito quindi
posso farlo rimbalzare sulle due volte
per adesso un chilometro fatto credo
quasi 900 35 metri è già qualcosa
oddio cosa cosa mi ha potenziato cosa
c'è e cosa mi ha cambiata a figo ci sono
le nuvole a sé piccole nuvole rimbalzo
meglio capito deve arrivare almeno un
chilometro jack perfetto ti adoro ma
abbiamo vinto tutto perfettissimo un
chilometro 132 metri già qualcosa
io devo arrivare qua spiega mi con che
fisica cosa devo devo prendere un aereo
di linea per arrivare lì non è possibile
cerchiamo di arrivare alla meteora che
vi farà fare qualcosa in più
mazza che calcio questo diretto proprio
perché va beh
ciao proprio sé ragazzi arrivo al km
senza neanche cadere per terra cioè devo
fantastico senza cadere per te jake devi
fare una cosa una devi solo ficcargli un
calcio quando arriva ce la puoi fare non
è difficile ma l'ho preso al massimo più
di così non posso fare regate
si vabbè se lo prende qualcos'altro mi
sa che muore direttamente crepa lì è
perfetto ok l'altro volo nello spazio
ok questa record di comunque se ciao
questo è il record mondiale un
chilometro e mezzo di più di più di un
chilometro e mezzo 1.700 metri come
possibile mai
ok ragazzi siamo arrivati a comprare la
meteora al finale proprio c'è di così
non possiamo prendere credo ce la
metterà il massimo dei potenziati
rimbalzi quindi adesso ce ne sono 3
quindi con tre con 3 rimbalzi mio dio
credo di no presa l'ho presa ciao
ma non è così potente e pensavo fosse
chissà che cosa non è vero se becco
qualcosa di nuovo record se beh se è
becco qualcosa ma non mi pare michael
tempismo è il mio secondo nome vuoi km
regate record totale assoluto non sono
arrivato no perché per arrivare
veramente lì ci metterò una vita e mezzo
però ho visto come funziona il gioco
provateci voi ad arrivargli se ci
arrivate non ci riuscirò mai nella vita
però passiamo all'altro gioco ragazzi a
farti addirittura film e jake e la
vettura epica ma addirittura l'avventura
è la lumachina linee torniamo
ma che sei script l'expo ragazzi
partiamo chi siamo chi siete
siete assit dei porci a però non capivo
cene dei porci grazie aver risposto alla
domanda chi siamo e andiamo su nuova
partita poi cosa devono succedere amico
siamo forse di nuovo finiti dentro primo
no stavolta guarda l'inter l'inter a
terra dio è stata trasformata in un
videogame ma posso usare anche jay che
ho fatto ha tratto posso spingere fin
sei stato un grande amico ma ora io ti
indurrà al suicidio addio film non devi
stare lì il film devi stare lì bravo
devi stare lì che devo frenare in corsa
oddio ciò uno scudo miglior gioco di
adventure time fino adesso provato dalla
partenza proprio se vuoi rivedere bimbo
portami dieci oggetti videogiochi ci
magici videogiochi ci ragazzi devo
trovare gli oggettivi i videogiochi ci
l'ora dello scontro arrivato premi
spazio per attaccare ma che voi umani ti
permetti porco credo che la le tessere
di esse riescono degli esseri sono porci
escano delle monete siamo proprio fuori
dai darci dentro raccoglierle va bene
chiavi cembalo mio amico mio tra
videogiochi c e chiavi cembalo non so
quale dei due è meglio su ogni livello
c'è un portale di accesso a quello
successivo trova la nazione lo premendo
spazio per passare al livello successivo
porco mi hai mancato via dai prova però
l'altra volta
oddio scusate ma allora devi morire
facciamo così che è meglio
ok come occuperò la vita
ecco lo regala l'ultimo non lo caga
che faccio qua ok secondo livello
ragazza non fatemi provare la cosa a lei
che mi daresti una mano sta cascando giu
grazie j
io sono cascato direttamente di sotto
fantastica sa cosa non tocco un nemico
neanche a pagarlo vado direttamente
portato nomi sta suicidando prendimi j j
sei un idiota non sai non serve a niente
nella vita quindi ragazzi devo andare
avanti e devo stare attento a non cadere
queste due cose devo fare quanto
estenuante questo viaggio qua è certo da
una roba mi pure portafogli non ho
capito chi era quello che i ragazzi non
ho neanche capito che stiamo andando
cioè sta andando avanti a caso allora
secondo i miei calcoli portale dovrebbe
trovarsi non di qua però qua a destra
così sta cosa
oddio questo prezzo cosa ho preso
ragazzi ho preso una roba strana vabbè
bella importante che vale bene ma è
meglio di niente da regalo niente la 1
prova a fare un regalo ti attaccano
amore
basta sono anni che continua a correre
basta la mitezza non trova il portale è
il portale parla parla porco quindi
ragazzi conclude episodio con un po di
amarezza per quanto riguarda il portale
per oh mio dio
veramente ho cercato ovunque e non c'è
sta cosa mi fa troppo strani effetti è
stranissimo ragazzi appunto pratici vuoi
se riuscite tanto ragazzi se volete
provarlo gioco lo trovate sul sito di
cartoon network come tutti gli altri
giochi
tecnologia il montaggio video che
spuntano le scritte fan ecco se
spuntasse riportali sarebbe meglio
si ricorda che i ragazzi questo video
andrà anche sul canale di cartoon
network e anche sul canale youtube di
cartoon network quindi potete vederlo
anche lì così come i video degli in
testa civich esiste stavolta vince tutta
la vita perché non 8 io non sono
riuscito
cioè io non sono riuscito chavin con la
sciarpa quindi ragazzi concludo qui e
spero che ai video vi sia piaciuto come
sensi vi è piaciuta sotto un commento è
un mi piace anche a facili facebook e
kameni video trattare descrizione se non
sei aversi discrete lì ci vediamo al
prossimo vinto dai ragazzi